scp-682 does it even require an
introduction the scp foundation thinks
this cantankerous reptile needs a
serious attitude adjustment by which we
mean they really really want to kill it
but as you might have seen in our
previous videos on the subject they
don't call this monstrosity the hard to
destroy reptile for nothing that's why
we've done what the foundation isn't
allowed to we outsource the dirty job of
squashing this lizard to all of you we
made a community post asking for your
ideas on how this scaly abomination can
finally be destroyed and you delivered
big time a truly staggering amount with
over 6 000 comments now let's see if we
can finally get our answer because
believe us the foundation is desperate
at this point i don't know what to write
for a name said the most effective way
that dr bright approves of chainsaw
cannon as awesome as a chainsaw cannon
would probably be to use it sadly
wouldn't be very effective against
scp-682
chainsaws are blades and we know from
the termination test logs that blades
have been ineffective even when scp-682
is chopped up into tiny little pieces
those pieces have a nasty habit of
reforming into the big ugly monster we
all know and fear awesome cardinals said
the scp foundation could try to bring it
to the void in russia where the pattern
screamers are this was a popular idea
and the foundation actually tried this
the scp being referred to here is
scp-3930
a big old pile of nothing in russia that
causes things inside it to stop existing
when they threw scp-682 inside it
technically did stop existing despite
this it could still be perceived and
still caused the deaths of all
surrounding researchers 15 hours later
it just reappeared in its containment
chamber apparently totally fine you can
probably see why the foundation is
frustrated by this thing scorecrow and
friends said black hole need i say more
you may need to say a little more for
starters there would be logistical
issues in actually getting the creature
anywhere near a black hole but there's
also the concern that it may just adapt
its body to respond to the intense
gravity present near a black hole or
even scarier somehow adapt to reproduce
the powers of a black hole it probably
wouldn't be worth the risk of ending up
with a reptile capable of creating
gamma-ray bursts stellar solar sky said
put the reptile inside nuclear fusion
and watch its particles disappear the
foundation tried something pretty close
to this by trying to put it inside
scp-536 a chamber where they can use
dials to control the physical contents
within they increased the speed of light
and nuclear force within the chamber
which caused scp-682 to disintegrate
until all that was left was a piece of
matter one percent of its original size
however the creature then reformed and
killed the researchers later tests
showed that its body had become an
unknown form of matter held together by
quantum effects impossible to unravel
with our current understanding of
science brea fun said so you know that
coffee machine thing that is 294 type in
682 killing substance and then repeat
that until you have enough to fill its
entire room then fill it they did
actually try this and the resulting
substance was effective in damaging
scp-682's tissue however the one problem
is that it's extremely difficult to
produce enough of this stuff to actually
submerge the creature worse still if
enough was made to cause significant
damage to the body of scp-682
it may adapt to the chemical as a
defense mechanism making it ineffective
as a weapon its adaptive ability is
truly
scp-682's greatest asset when it comes
to thwarting the foundation's constant
attempts to kill it alex webb said ask
it kindly to die we don't believe that
the foundation has actually ever tried
this one but just based on the fact that
scp-682 is a huge jerk on top of being
an omnicidal monster he probably
wouldn't respond to polite requests
iflashboy said i wonder if doomslayer
could defeat the reptile he's torn
through every demon in hell and even
titans so would 682 be a challenger or
just another tuesday for the slayer
that's a slightly trickier one of course
since they exist in different universes
we'll never see an official battle
between the doom slayer and scp-682
however given that the doom slayer's
weapons are all conventional meaning
largely based around slashing crushing
shooting and blasting we don't know
whether he'd actually be able to slay
the beast that being said we don't know
if 682 could kill him either we could
have a stalemate on our hands here
amanda brennaman said i asked my sister
who's never heard of scps this question
and her answer was you hit it again
amanda your sister may be the one to
finally stop this creature getting the
two of them in the same room may be the
biggest logistical problem here samuel
pascual said throwing him down scp-087
so he suffers and is contained once and
for all in the improbable case he is
still alive scp-087
the endless staircase can be a dangerous
anomaly for humans who don't know what
they're getting into however scp-682
would likely detect the threat far
earlier than any human and then breach
containment it's definitely gotten out
of stickier situations yashashiri shara
said send him to endless ikea where he
will be trapped forever much like
scp-087 the endless ikea wouldn't pose
the same threat to scp-682 as it would
for the average human trapped inside the
staff would be no trouble for 682 and it
would be able to devote pretty much all
of its time in there to finding a way
out and when he did finally break out
he'd probably be armed with a terrifying
knowledge of how to correctly assemble a
svendinthrook we shudder at the thought
jack law said oxygen destroyer used to
deal with another big lizard issue back
in 1954. sadly this would also likely be
an ineffective weapon against
scp-682 because the creature thrives in
anaerobic environments seeing as its
native atmosphere seems to have no
oxygen and according to foundation tests
it can survive just fine in a vacuum
whether scp-682 could take godzilla in a
fight is still up for debate and you can
argue about which lizard would reign
supreme in the comments ace goodwin said
just don't kill him let him live bro he
hasn't done anything wrong yet let him
vibe in his chamber wait a second did
scp 682 write this
moving on a lot of you said throw him
into the sun while the sun is a gigantic
nuclear furnace where hydrogen is built
into helium at a temperature of millions
of degrees there is the issue of not
only being beyond difficult to
incapacitate the creature for long
enough to get into the rocket but also
the problem of the sun being 93 million
miles away from earth it's a long trip
there no matter what and during that
time scp-682 would almost definitely
figure out a way to return to earth it
might even rewire the rocket and turn it
into its own personal vehicle giving it
the freedom to cause chaos around the
solar system and even if everything else
went well
scp-682 would still probably survive
being thrown into the sun after all the
gate guardian's flaming sword is
described as being hotter than the sun
and it didn't manage to kill the
hard-to-destroy reptile pokemon redboy
said send him to mars and launch a nuke
that can destroy a planet along with the
scp while a nuke capable of destroying
the planet of mars would also likely
destroy scp-682 in the process the
destruction of mars itself would likely
cause such a catastrophic shift in our
neck of the solar system that we'd
probably die along with it the question
at that point is whether it's really
worth killing ourselves to take down the
lizard artemis said let it live with 999
in its entire life and it's not a threat
this is a double-edged sword during
their cross test
scp-999 did pacify scp-682 and put it in
a state of bliss and laughter for a
brief period however this actually
resulted in a pretty catastrophic
tragedy too 682 adapted to 999's effects
and released a beam of laughter that
incapacitated everyone around it
allowing it to escape and go on a
killing spree so maybe the two are
better kept apart doctor was upset i'd
give 682 a jar of pickles to open and
the jar would be so tight that scp-682
couldn't open it and he would be so
embarrassed by it that he would just
destroy himself you may actually be on
to something here we know we'd be
extremely embarrassed if we couldn't
open the jar but there are three major
problems one where does one get such a
jar can scp-343 make a jar of pickles so
difficult to open that he himself can
open it two we don't know if scp-682
likes pickles enough to make opening the
jar an attractive prospect and three if
it does turn out that it likes pickles
it would probably just eat the jar too
shuvo batacharji said to deal with him
in my opinion send scp-682 into
scp-3001 aka the red reality that's my
theory this could potentially be an
effective method of trapping scp-682 for
a period of time however the problem is
that there's no reliable way to access
the red reality the only person who's
ever really been inside is robert
scranton and he ended up there
completely by accident so this doesn't
seem to be a reliable neutralization
method for scp-682
adding to that the panel that dr
scranton was transported to the red
reality with eventually came back which
means it might only be a temporary
solution anyway mistake to society yay
said can someone ride scp-682 without
them dying this isn't technically about
neutralizing
scp-682 but it deserves an answer while
it appears that some people are able to
ride 682 such as
scp-053 the little girl and 05-6 aka the
american in the orboro cycle he doesn't
seem to enjoy it at least he didn't when
scp-082 better known as ferdinand the
cannibal attempted it of course
ferdinand describes their relationship
quite differently insisting that 682 is
his bayard his magical steed laura
garcia said chop it up put the pieces in
a giant bowl with eggbeaters stirring it
constantly so it can't reanimate keep it
kinetically moving so it doesn't ever
have the rest time to reform giant egg
beating machine to prevent reformation
killing it would take a rival sunblast
to stop it from reanimating itself this
has got to be one of the most creative
ones we've encountered even dr bry
probably wouldn't think to use giant
whisks on the beast however it probably
wouldn't kill the ornery creature for
good as we've said before not only has
the beast regenerated from things as hot
as the sun he's also able to remanifest
from the tiniest atoms or even nothing
at all on the plus side he may reanimate
with a new super whisking ability and
could potentially give
scp-5031 a run for best cook and
containment shaked ben yakar said i
think they need to explode him from the
inside because maybe there's one spot in
this body that isn't invincible and if
they heard it scp-682 will die the
problem with scp-682 isn't necessarily
that it's invincible just hyper-adaptive
and hyper-regenerative as you may have
seen in other videos
scp-682 has been shot dismembered burned
frozen vaporized blown up partially
eaten and even totally disintegrated but
it always manages to come back even from
the smallest specks of matter it would
almost be admirable if it wasn't a
perpetually aggressive murder monster
brybot said put it in 106 his pocket
dimension this actually happened once
during a containment breach where the
old man as well as scp-953 the
polymorphic humanoid ended up in 682's
cell
scp-106 dragged them all into its pocket
dimension for a bit of the odd ultra
violence and when they emerged it was
clear that they'd all taken considerable
damage
scp-682 wasn't killed though and 106
hasn't tried anything like that again
since non-player cactus said trick him
into killing john wick's dog to be fair
if anyone could take this monster down
it'd probably be john wick though
scp-682 might be too smart to actually
kill his dog in the first place and if
he did manage to best john weck well we
hate to think what a 682 with the
martial prowess and gun skills of john
wick would be like actually no we don't
hate to think about it because it would
be awesome these are just a little
taster plate of the huge and varied
potential murder methods you've devised
for this terrible creature but there
were just too many good ones so we'll
have to save the rest for another day
which means it isn't too late to tell us
yours let us know your idea down in the
comments and make sure to subscribe turn
on notifications and keep an eye on our
community tab so you can be part of the
next video now check out
scp-5031 yet another murder monster and
scp-682 waze scp foundation tried to
kill hard to destroy reptile for more on
monsters kept under the foundation's
care